yo
yo it's dave rubin this is the
reubenport direct message
i am fresh off the plane from the swamp
that's right i spent 24 hours in dc
i went to the white house hanukkah party
yesterday i was outside the west wing i
was in the white house
i took pictures i ate the white house
sushi yeah there's white house sushi
and uh and had had a good time uh
i posted a little video yesterday if you
didn't see it i did a little wandering
around dc video selfie style
with my bodyguard slash accountant slash
agent
uh kyle kashu if you guys know kyle and
uh
it's very bizarre if you haven't seen
the video just watch it it's just a
couple minutes long wandering around dc
dc is an
absolute ghost town it is
seriously weird we did not see humans i
mean a couple homeless people
you know wandering around and then some
trash in different places
but there were basically no humans
anywhere in dc at the white house
there were some humans and i stayed at
the trump hotel there were some people
there
but but that was about it it was it was
really weird and kind of depressing and
i suppose a sign of the times i mean i
absolutely love dc i
love the history of dc i love going to
the
monuments i love going to the museums i
love walking around the mall like just
the the power
of it the everything's huge the
buildings are massive
i'm sure most of you at least from uh
those of you that who are american have
been there
um but if you haven't been there go i
mean unfortunately everything's kind of
closed right now so you may want to wait
a little bit
but it was you know kind of brisk and
cold and gray as dc can be this time of
year
and it was just depressing no tourists
no people
everything closed it was hard to find a
place to go to lunch and actually
we did this little video and the only
humans that i saw we saw three guys and
they happened they happened to know me
they happened to be fans of the show
they were the only three people that we
saw as we were wanting around it was
it was really bizarre uh the the party
was great though and it was really cool
obviously to
to be at the white house and uh if you
if you haven't seen the video
uh from yesterday take a look at that uh
there's a there's a bunch to talk about
today
and i just want to say one thing before
we get into it
uh i was really feeling in the day
and even leading up to the day like i am
really in case it's not obvious to you
guys at this point i
am really ready to fight i am really
ready to fight there there are so many
bad
trends happening right now from the
confusion over the election
to the endless lockdowns to the fact
that our mainstream media has just
failed us at every front
every front there is like there's just
nothing they haven't failed us on
i just want you guys to know i am
absolutely ready to fight and part of
that comes
not just because it's kind of within me
right now and i guess my whole life kind
of led up to this so so here we are
whether i like it or not
um but also the amount of messages i'm
getting from you guys and the amount of
people that i met at the
at the party yesterday and at the hotel
people coming up to me
just saying that i had something to do
with their awakening or i'm fighting
because they can't because they don't
want to lose their job and everything
else it's like we all just need like a
dose of bravery right now
wouldn't that be something if instead of
getting injected with a vaccine all we
just need
is an injection of bravery because i
kind of think that's where we're at
uh before i get into everything else
real quick i also bumped into judge
jeanine
uh at the hotel believe it or not i'd
never met her i do her show all the time
but we had
actually never met in person so it was
nice to see her there and then at the
hotel i bumped into sydney powell
and we chatted for just a minute and i
asked her if she's feeling good about
everything and if she really believes
that things are going to happen and all
that
and she does so as i've said from b1
it's not just what she believes or what
she says it'll ultimately be about what
she can prove in court
and you know that's uh
that remains to be seen and that will
sort of get us into story number one
but before we do that guys i want to
talk to you about glint pay
because as you know you can use your
glint pay card to buy and sell
gold you can not only do that but you
can use your glint pay card which also
acts as a mastercard
to make transactions so you can buy a
cup of coffee you can buy clothes
whatever it is that you buy do you buy
stuff these days
whatever it is toilet paper or paper
towels you can buy with your glint pay
card
and using the app you can actually
choose whether you're gonna pay in gold
or in u.s dollars so it acts like a
regular mastercard in that way it's a
pretty beautiful thing
guys the glint pay card is issued by
sutton bank which is a member of the
fdic pursuant to license
from mastercard international it's free
to sign up so go to glintpay.comruben
for more info and to start purchasing
gold today that's glintpay.com
reuben to get your gold today and now
back to me
all right so this is the story this is
the story we're doing four stories today
because there's obviously a bunch going
on but this
is the story if you only hear one story
today whether it's for me or somebody
else
this is the thing you gotta pay
attention to um
and it has a little bit to do with what
we do right here
so yesterday as i was uh i was waiting
for kyle at the
at the hotel and i just bumped into
judge jeanine i open up my email and i
have an email
from our contact at youtube now for
years i didn't have a contact at youtube
uh now we have a contact at youtube coca
i'll give you a little shout out who i
who i really like i think she's a great
gal and she's helped us
uh deal with some of the non the general
nonsense at
youtube but i got an email from from
coco that obviously went out to all
sorts of creators
um about election fraud content
and what youtube will be censoring so
it's a long email i'm just going to read
two parts of it directly from youtube
this is the exact email that i got
yesterday starting today
we will remove new content uploaded on
or
after december 9th 2020 alleging that
widespread
fraud or errors changed the outcome of
the 2020 u.s presidential election
for example we will remove videos
claiming that a presidential candidate
won the election as a result of
widespread software
glitches or counting errors it goes on
to say
if your content is impacted you will
receive
automated emails from our system
regarding this content
as we ramp up our enforcement we'll like
will initially remove
viola violative videos without giving a
strike
we will begin issuing strikes for new
content uploaded after inauguration day
january 20th 21. um
man there is a lot there and that
directly affects
everything that i do i think it probably
affects our ability
as human beings to communicate in an
open and honest way
and there's just so much to talk about i
don't even know where to start so i'll
start with
before we even get into what's going on
now i would like you to do a quick
search about russiagate on youtube about
russia or ukraine infecting our 2016
election quotes from hillary clinton
saying it was an illegitimate election
nancy pelosi saying the same thing all
of the democrats running around
swalwell who it's now turned out eric
swalwell it's now turned out he was
sleeping with a chinese spy
him talking about how donald trump jr is
a russian asset
the amount of misinformation on youtube
is extraordinary it's
actually unquantifiable there's probably
no way
that even a machine could count the
amount of misinformation
that's on this website putting aside the
controlled misinformation that is our
mainstream media
the idea that youtube is now deciding
okay
this issue about the 2020 election
while we have lawsuits working through
the system right now which i'll talk
about in a moment
now if you even say i'm not saying it
right now by the way youtube if you're
watching i'm not saying there was
widespread for it i'm saying that if you
say there was widespread fraud
that they're gonna they're gonna harm
your channel meaning they're gonna
either take down your videos you're
gonna get an email and then eventually
you get a strike and if you get three
strikes you're basically out they can
delete your channel they can demonetize
you
and the rest of it so it is only by the
grace of the youtube gods that any of us
are here i understand that and they are
a private company to some extent
although they obviously have a lot of
connections
with the government and youtube in
essence is the new public square
but the idea that they're saying oh you
know you can watch there's all sorts of
alien conspiracies there's all sorts of
nazi conspiracies
there's all sorts of insane
psychotic lunacy on this here
youtube.com
but this is the thing that's starting
today it's literally starting today
we will remove videos claiming that a
presidential candidate won as a riddle
of widespread software glitches or
accounters so i guess you could say he
won in other ways so it's you can't say
that it was widespread software that did
it
or or counting errors i mean that just
seems
very odd like there's things working
through the courts right now but even if
you
said it even if you said it donald trump
and i'm not saying it but even if you
said it
that donald trump won by counting errors
and then you showed some of the videos
that we've showed some of the confusing
things happening out of georgia
some of the things that are being
alleged in the courts right now about
double voting and the rest of it
why wouldn't that be left to stand and
by the way they can put warnings on
things right they've been putting
warnings on a lot of the youtube videos
about the results of the election and
trump every time he tweets has a warning
about something
but now they're saying we can actually
crush you in your livelihood
and i would say guys basically we have
we have a giant superstructure that in
essence now exists
over the united states government
something that our founders could have
never imagined our founders
said that the state the government will
not infringe
on your ability to speak freely right
that's the
in essence what the first amendment is
but they couldn't imagine that companies
that corporations could become so large
that it wouldn't matter
whether the government was coming for me
in other words you could say whatever
you want about the election donald
trump's not coming for you you can
every time donald trump says something a
gajillion blue check people
journalists jump on there and tell him
he's going to end up in jail and he
should rot in hell and everything else
donald trump doesn't come for everybody
i suspect it'll be a little different
if the left comes to power but the point
is that the fear
around free speech as i've been saying
for years isn't that the government is
coming per se that's always something to
worry about
but the fear now is that these giant
corporations will tell us what is and
isn't true
and also let's remember two or three
weeks before the election this is little
insider baseball but it's important to
understand how these things happen
two or three weeks before the election
twitter changed their retweet policy so
it used to be you could just tap the
retweet button and it would get sent out
to all your followers
then they change it so you had to tap it
it would take you to another screen and
you had to tap it again
no one was asking them to do that but
clearly there was discussions going
how are we going to control the speed
that information gets out there
so they changed that i said something
about it but very few people did
then in the subsequent weeks after the
election every time
donald trump tweets they say the elect
this information is disputed now they
never say it about joe biden joe biden
can say i'm the president-elect they
don't say it's disputed but but it is
disputed right it's disputed because the
president of the united states is
disputing it
so who's in charge of the disputation
there's a word for you um so that's a
little something and now youtube is
coming in saying
if you even talk about this if you just
talk about any of this stuff
we're going to take you out so by the
way this is why i started locals.com
all of my stuff is free uh free of
censorship and
and free of manipulation at
reubenreport.com uh you pay what you
want to get in there in essence and you
get all my stuff
ad free and it was my little way of
fighting the the big tech monster
i want to show you uh two tweets from
tim poole by the way you guys know tim
paul i've had him on the show a bunch
i would say he's on the short list of
people that i can call journalists
without putting quotes around the word
journalist
um and i've got the tweets over here do
we have do i have the tweets
do i have the tweets from tim oop i
don't think i have the tweets from tim
where'd the tweets go oh i do have them
here
got a lot of papers here today we're
very professional organization
uh so the two tweets from tim uh youtube
has clarified to me
you can still say trump actually won the
election
you can still claim that the election
was stolen from trump
you must meet two conditions for a video
to be removed
you must claim widespread fraud or error
okay we just addressed that
and say it made trump lose so i can say
right now there's widespread fraud or
error but i just can't say that that is
why trump lost
apparently according to tim poole he's
pretty solid he says
you can still say there is evidence of
widespread fraud so i will say that
there appears to be evidence of
widespread fraud there are thousands of
affidavits
signed by people who were election
regulators you can still say trump
actually won you cannot combine the two
what strange times we live in so yes
folks we do live in strange times and
for those of you that wanted the
government to do something about this
they had all their hearings and they
were they were basically just theater
and this was this was a very tough one
as i've mentioned to you guys many times
for the more libertarian-minded people
what do you do
i would say at this point at this unique
part in history
if the government which is only designed
to protect our rights
meaning protect our right to free speech
protect
our right to assembly which we kind of
don't have anymore but protect those
things enshrined in the constitution
and the bill of rights if the government
can't do that or refuses to do that
because there are these superstructures
these
giant technological corporations that
exist above the government
well then in essence what the hell is
the government for if you live in los
angeles the government won't even arrest
you if you're trespassing and
literally soliciting prostitution on
someone else's property and then you
resist arrest
our new our new d.a here in los angeles
gascon who was the former d.a of san
francisco and ruined that place
backed by bernie uh he's now in charge
of la and they're not going to arrest
you you can literally
trespass onto someone's property you can
solicit prostitution
and if you do those things and resist
arrest when they come for you
they will do nothing they will not
prosecute the case
we are in dystopia ladies and gentlemen
we are in dystopia
um anyway there's obviously going to be
more about this and i will keep
talking about what is happening with
these cases
and and we'll see if they come for me i
mean
what am i supposed to do am i just gonna
be quiet because the big tech overlords
deem me to be quiet there are court
cases okay
and let's talk about those court cases
right now because 17
states have now filed a brief supporting
the great state of texas to delay the
presidential elector appointment so i've
got a couple quotes here
from fox news so missouri led a group of
17
states that wednesday so this is
yesterday wednesday afternoon filed a
brief with the supreme court
supporting the texas lawsuit aimed at
delaying the appointment of presidential
electors
from georgia pennsylvania michigan and
wisconsin so 17 other states have now
joined that lawsuit that texas brought
about
those four states it goes on to say the
brief mirrors the argument of the texas
suit
in saying that the states acted
unconstitutionally when either their
judiciaries or executive branches
changed their election laws the texas
suit and the states that support it
say that only state legislatures may set
laws regarding how states appoint
their presidential electors okay
so these are things that are happening
right now
so if it comes out through any of these
court cases
if it comes out that in any of these
court cases
that that votes were changed
or that something happened with dominion
or that
there was any malfeasance or weirdness
well a we should know about that
wouldn't you want to know about that i
think across the aisle we
would all want free and fair elections
i'm actually not so sure about that but
i think most people
want free and fair elections not just so
not something that's just rigged so that
they get what they want
but in essence we now have 17 states uh
that are on board this thing so
including texas now you've got you've
got 18
states okay and we are
entering a very weird time we are
entering a very weird time and as i said
last week
you know my feeling is that regardless
of what the
truth here is at the moment regardless
of what the truth
is about election fraud or was it was it
done absolutely perfectly i mean the
fact that youtube doesn't want you to
talk about it mainstream is ignoring it
if anything that in and of itself makes
it seem like it's more legit right like
if every day the mainstream media was
covering and say oh we had these
we had these hearings today and these
regular citizens put their butts on the
line
to say these things but they're all
they're all crazy people or something
like that well if you guys were covering
it
well then it wouldn't seem so weird but
the more they say oh don't look over
there the more that the average person
because they've shot their load already
right they've
they've i'm trying to be cleaner this
week they've busted their nut
well that didn't work either they've you
get what i'm saying people they've
they've done such a poor job of doing
what they're supposed to do that the
more they ignore something at this point
the more legit
it seems that that seems to be what's
happening here and uh this ain't going
away i'm gonna keep talking about it
and again as i've said from day one
from day one if all of it gets through
the courts look the supreme court will
either take this case or not now
from what i understand it's on the
docket at the supreme court that does
not mean they have to take the case
now that 18 states are in it does seem
like there's going to be a certain
amount of pressure for them to do it
but but the question is this regardless
of what is
actually true here my feeling is that
trump basically has more support now
than he did before
the election because you've got
basically all of the people who
supported him and i've found very few
people that don't think something weird
happened
just something weird right and then
you've got all of these other people who
are now seeing endless lockdowns lives
being destroyed
and you know i went to the to the rally
in los angeles to open up the
restaurants a couple days ago and most
of the people there they're not
republicans
they're not trump supporters in a
traditional sense they're people that
just want to live
and they're suddenly going oh it's the
democrats that are trying to destroy our
lives and then what the next logical
step is from that
in an odd unfortunate way is oh well i
guess i guess
trump's better than that i don't even
mean that in an unfortunate way i mean
it in like
it's just a strange political reality
that we have it's like oh the democrats
are horrible so
here's the other guy maybe i should look
at that so i sense he has a little more
support than he did before
but speaking of support if you want to
support a healthy lifestyle
i want you to look at a new protein bar
that tastes like a candy bar people i've
been talking about built bars
and they are just the brand for you
built bars are super tasty and come in
18 amazing flavors
my favorite is the cookies and cream
which i've got right here built bars are
covered in 100
chocolate including both nut and nut
free flavors and are soft
and easy to chew with the holidays just
around the corner it's easy to slip
up which is why built bars are the
perfect alternative to pie
for the health conscious guy i can
actually lose or maintain weight while
indulging in a delicious treat built
bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein
and high fiber you guys can go to
builtbar.com and use promo code ruben
and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at billbar.com good for bars built
go or build
boost and now that to me
all right
here's a doozy for you let's talk about
that covet thing again because
this this story is is quite curious
uh cornell university you know cornell
university is in upstate new york i went
to suny binghamton state university of
new york at binghamton it's the
it's the public school that everyone
said was the cornell of the public
uh school education of the public school
system it was about 45 minutes
from uh from cornell i had some friends
that that went to cornell
uh i know a lot of people that have been
to cornell i visited cornell a few times
at one time i don't know if this is
still true at one time it was the
suicide capital
of the world in terms of colleges
because they've got these gorges
uh just these giant cavernous gorges
that people would just jump off the
bridges
they used to say ithaca which is where
cornell is ithaca is gorges
instead of ithaca is gorgeous get it
well anyway cornell university which is
you know an ivy league school i i think
it's a still a respected university at
least in some
circles where universities are still
respected uh they've decided
that there's going to be an exemption
for flu vaccines if you're a person of
color now before i read the quotes let
me just
do that again there's going to be an
exemption
for flu vaccine if you're a person of
color now i thought the flu vaccine was
good
i thought we don't want covet and if
anything in the world of social justice
you would want to get
the vaccine to the people who need it
most in which case they would tell you
this is people of color
they would tell you this is downtrodden
people people who have been oppressed
systemically oppressed right so wouldn't
you want to get them the vaccine first
if the vaccine is good don't you want to
do good things
for these people i thought that's what
the whole thing was but you know me i'm
a simple guy
here's a quote from campus reform
students at cornell university
can use their status as a person of
color to be exempt from the university's
flu vaccine requirement now again this
seems
this seems odd to me i i thought we like
the vaccine
i thought that 95 of the people will be
uh will be immune after the vaccine even
though this disease in the first place
this virus in the first place has a 99
recovery rate but you would imagine that
if a group of people were marginalized
and then the government was coming in
and saying we can vaccinate you that we
could get you to the front of the line
so i'm still
very very confused so let's go to quote
directly from cornell university itself
we recognize that due to long-standing
systemic racism
and health inequities in this country
individuals from some marginalized
communities
may have concerns about needing to agree
to such requirements
for example historically the bodies of
black
indigenous and other people of color
have been mistreated and used by people
in power
sometimes for profit or medical gain
there's a lot there um okay i think i
made my point that if this thing is
supposedly good
and we're trying to help you know
marginalized
uh groups that you'd think they'd want
it first but the rest of this
what cornell in essence is saying is
there is oh
if there's a problem with this thing we
kind of don't want to test it out
on black people first or indigenous
people first because there could be an
issue and we wouldn't want them to
suffer from first hey whitey
whitey can you uh get up get up in line
for this thing we don't we don't we rush
it through we don't know exactly what's
going to happen so
white people that'll that'll be instead
of reparations could you guys just take
this first and we'll see what happens
with that would that be better
the level of stupidity here and this is
what social justice does with everything
social justice takes something that is
supposed to be good right supposed to be
good in this case vaccinations
by the way i'm not taking the
vaccination they can try to vaccinate me
i'm not taking it um but uh because i'm
not taking a vaccine
that has a you know for a for a virus
with a 99 recovery rate
as a relatively young healthy person
like i just see no reason to do that
but i would welcome anyone that wants to
take it to take it i believe in personal
choice i know that's a that's a crazy
radical
position these days um but this is what
social justice does with everything none
of this really makes sense
if they will tell us on one hand that
that black and brown
and indigenous communities are harmed
more by by covid
then they will tell you okay we've got a
vaccination for kovid
but we're not going to give it to them
because of some sort of historic
systemic rate
none of it makes sense this is this is
absolute
drivel and nonsense and our universities
have been completely corrupted
by nonsensical lunacy all right let's
move on to the next segment
uh gavin newsom you know gavin newsom
he's our horrific
governor i almost said mayor that's you
eric garcetti he's our horrific
governor here in the people's republic
of california well his
health secretary was on a zoom call
chatting and he actually admitted the
thing that we all know
he admitted that shutting down outdoor
dining in california
has nothing to do with public safety
yeah nothing to do with public safety
don't take my word for it though
uh let's listen to him himself
they're going to be the tools that help
us get this
under control so the decision to include
among
other sectors outdoor dining and
limiting that
turning to restaurants to deliver and
provide takeout options instead
really has to do with the goal of trying
to keep people
at home not a comment on
the relative safety of outdoor dining
and we have worked hard with
that industry to create safer ways for
outdoor dining to happen
to keeping tables farther apart
to ensuring masking happens as much as
possible
to create opportunities for air
circulation
to continue all of those factors make
sectors like outdoor dynein lower risk
but right now
with the levels of transmission that
we're seeing we advise against anything
that you can
do in another way in a lower risk way
that avoids you either leaving your home
or only leaving your home in a way
that uh doesn't expose you and cause you
to mix with
god these people are absolutely
ridiculous so to be clear that's
california health secretary mark
galley i believe that's how you
pronounce his last name uh that was on a
zoom conference for california health
and human services
i got two quotes there that he said that
were these are just
incredible he says quote the goal of
trying to keep
people at home dot dot not the relative
safety of outdoor dining meaning that
they understand that
the relative safety of outdoor dining is
totally fine we have
no evidence no evidence but prove me
wrong people
no evidence that outdoor dining
transmits kobit there is no evidence of
it and let's not forget
we are not in new york we are not in dc
on the east coast where it's the middle
of the winter right now and it's 32
degrees outside
we are in los angeles i am wearing
shorts right now and i look very
professional
but i'm wearing shorts okay i'm not even
wearing socks and
we are in a constant uh beautiful
weather
section of the world it's about 80 and
sunny every single day
the idea that people can't sit outside
is crazy and he knows it
because he specifically says this is
about trying to keep people at home
which in essence is we're trying to
destroy their lives uh
not the relative safety of outdoor
outdoor dining which they know
the relative safety of outdoor dining is
just fine and oh and he also said that
they worked
hard about outdoor dining and then they
closed it right so
they worked hard they worked hard they
had no evidence that it didn't work
and then the woman whose uh house i
protested at last week sheila cool who's
one of the
the county supervisors in los angeles
she was the deciding vote
three to two to close down all of these
restaurants to close down all of these
bars
while it's beautiful outside while
people need to get out of their houses
while we need to converse
and be social creatures that humans are
and then what did this
creature this awful person do
she went to an outdoor restaurant to
have her lasagna
these are bad people these are bad
people that want to control you and i
don't know how much more it's going to
take
to get people to wake up and and see
what's going on here that is that
that does not mean that covet is a hoax
it is not a hoax
it is a virus and it can affect people
and especially if you have
another sickness cancer a compromised
immune system
lung issues all of those things if
you're a certain age you have to take
more precautions
but we are almost a year i mean we're
rolling into
a year of this and if you think that
these lockdowns now
are are about keeping us safe
i am much more concerned about being
kept safe from these people
than than i am from covid okay and
finally this just broke i'm just going
to do a minute or two on it
this just broke like in the last hour uh
remember that middle east peace thing
that was that sort of dream it was that
distant
star that people had been talking about
for decades we want
peace in the middle east that's the
place that can never have peace it's
geographically tough
there are these religious reasons we
can't have peace these cultural reasons
we can't have peace well in essence
donald trump has been president for four
years we have had no wars in the middle
east we've scaled back at a
out of syria uh we we know we're moving
out of afghanistan that's
that's a wider conversation about what
is happening sort of with our with our
military and and we are not
nation-building and everything else
um but israel has now signed a
peace deal with morocco now i already
have seen this on twitter people going
well they weren't directly at war
but they weren't at peace either and the
more that these countries exchange
commerce and exchange ambassadors and
say
hey you have a right to exist i have a
right to exist
the more that peace actually can
flourish so the quote from ap news
is israel and morocco have agreed to
normalize relations president donald
trump said thursday
marking the fourth arab israeli
agreement in four months
as part of the deal announced near the
end of trump's term the united states
will recognize morocco's claim over the
disputed western sahara region so that
that's a separate issue which maybe i'll
talk about on the show
at a different time but the idea
that israel and morocco now in essence
are at peace
you know there's a lot of moroccan jews
who were kicked out of morocco and ended
up living in israel okay
uh during the arab-israeli war in 48 and
right before and right after
like these these countries in essence
although they haven't been bombing each
other
for the last 50 years in essence they've
been at a sort of cold war
we've now seen four arab countries sign
these deals
this is good this is good like you don't
even have to care about the middle east
like i actually don't think most people
care about the middle east most people
just want america
to sort of not police the world that
that's my position actually i would just
prefer america not to police the world
but in the cases where we can use our
leverage
to help countries have peace and then
not get us
caught in all of these crazy quagmires
it's like that's good
and i suppose it's unfortunate for a lot
of people with trump derangement
syndrome that
that the orange man is the one that is
bringing peace to the middle east
and uh and if you haven't seen it google
it or youtube it there is an
extraordinarily it's actually hilarious
you can find a hilarious video of john
kerry who is an
absolute buffoon who has accomplished
nothing in all of his years he was a
failed presidential candidate
he's had a lot of botox or it might be
ketchup he injects in his face because
you know he
he married the the heinz woman uh so
he's got access to tremendous amounts of
ketchup
but but putting aside that uh there's a
great video of him
uh as he was uh what was was he
secretary of state i think
as he was secretary of state in the
obama administration can you fact that
fact that for me um talking about how
you
cannot have peace with these other
nations you must have peace
with the palestinians first and actually
everything he says
and he's no no no you must do it our way
secretary of state right
you must do it our way and that's what
he was doing as an outgoing guy under
obama yeah it was secretary of state i
fact checked myself
you see what we do around here i don't
wait for big tech to do it for me
i don't wait for an activist working at
facebook i fact check myself um
but he literally everything he says has
been proven wrong and four of these
deals had
has have come and by the way if one of
these deals
had come under president obama people
would be giving him the double
the super nobel prize right he got the
nobel prize for doing nothing he'd get
he'd be getting the super nobel if this
had happened so
so here we are so even in what
potentially are trump's last
you know five six weeks and and again
i'm still not sure of that and i will
keep talking about it no matter what
youtube wants me to do
there there are good things happening
out there there really are so
so that's that uh all right guys i gotta
jump gotta got a hectic day of
interviews and a couple other things
a quick reminder guys tomorrow our dm
we're normally
at 11 a.m pacific uh but i'm pre-taping
the greg gutfeld show
so we will be live at 1 15 pacific which
is 4 15
p.m eastern uh i just want to say i'm
thrilled to see that our our numbers
have
absolutely been blowing up i mean just
every every week basically is a
record-breaking week and that's been
happening
for months and uh and as i always say i
hope i'm
making you feel a little saner but get
out there fight for what you believe in
and uh we'll be back tomorrow all right